new details tonight after a woman was
killed by a robbery suspect wednesday
night 60 year old alicia gabalina was
the manager at a dottie's who died
chasing after a man who stole a woman's
purse more than 24 hours later metro
police are still looking for that driver
the car he was in last night believed to
be stolen we thank you for joining us at
11 i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez this tragic incident last night
contributing now to a spike in crime in
the southwest valley because we've also
learned of a robbery targeting a mail
carrier sasha loft has heard from
concerned neighbors tonight joining us
live with more right now sasha
brian and denise a memorial is growing
here where alicia was killed in this
parking lot last night this is the
latest example of an uptick in violent
crime in this area that others concerned
it's very scary people living in spring
valley say they're concerned over a
recent wave of crime i grew up almost
half my life and i went to school here
and it just changed a lot on wednesday
the manager of this dotties at jones and
flamingo was run over and killed after
confronting a man who stole a customer's
purse then thursday morning a u.s postal
service carrier was robbed down the
street near twain and arville it is
crazy a lot of stuff out here in las
vegas it's unsettling to see one of
these things happen but with two in a
row many who live nearby aren't sure
what to expect i know where i see it in
the community it's quite but when you
come out the gate you never know what
you're going to get metro police say
crime across the southwest valley has
skyrocketed so far this year with the
number of robberies doubling compared to
this time in 2021 i really don't come
out i go to the store in the daytime go
catch my bus those we spoke with say
this is making them think twice it's
just very scary it's scared to live in
the world nowadays as they look out for
themselves and everyone they love it
just feels safe
authorities say the postal worker that
was robbed in this area today is okay as
for the suspect police say hit the
manager of this dotties here that person
is still on the run as we mentioned
driving a black mercedes gl5 with the
license plate 565
t-77 if you have any information call
metro police or crime stoppers reporting
live tonight sasha loftis live local now